you know what chechi PT is really good
at is and all these large language
models ultimately are very good at is um
filler boilerplate you know stuff that
is like that is not that is not
necessarily like uh a personal
expression right like and I think one
thing that's going to happen is you're
going to see a lot more uh emphasis on
the personal on the intention of the
author of an essay that that was my
education was how to do that and Chachi
BT does really it doesn't break into the
power of the intention it doesn't break
the power of being able to make an
argument but it definitely breaks like
the the just simply being able to put
things in a paragraph in a good
structure in a way that makes sense
right and you know that was a very
hard-fought skill for me and now you can
do it with a click of a button
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome back to the
podcast futurist author writer for the
Atlantic you may know him as the author
of this great book the next civil war my
friend Stephen Marsh welcome Steven
always good to talk to you Andrew how
you doing doing great so we are going to
chat chat GPT which is the natural
language processing uh app that has
taken the World by storm You're
Something of an expert uh because you've
been digging into this for years since
uh back in 2017 or even earlier
yeah I mean before 2017 I was sort of a
skeptic of digital Humanities and one of
the things that you know sometimes when
you get skeptical skeptical about things
you start to look into them and then you
also you do but continue yeah
but you know I I was I was very
skeptical of these metrical systems for
analyzing things and so I sort of
started looking into it and then as I
looked into it I was like oh my God
there's some really interesting stuff
happening here and you know the first
sort of I used uh you know an
algorithmic method of generating a short
story for the wired in 2017 and then I
did another one for the MIT tech review
and then the Transformer happened the
Transformer is the uh the technology
that makes it's the T in GPT and it
makes all of this stuff possible and
it's really kind of splitting the atom
of language and uh you know since then
I've been following its effects pretty
closely and
um and seeing sort of the you know the
Trend to me is much broader than chat
GPT like chat GPT is the hot thing right
now yeah you know things that have been
incredibly cool uh have been around for
you know at least two or three years and
sort of mind-blowing it's just you know
with chat GPT the the people are
catching up on it they're basically
seeing it happen which is a is a large
language model it's a it's a bot that
you can ask any question and it produces
a coherent response to it you have to
remember that all of this stuff all of
natural language processing is simply
text prediction software like that's all
it is it all it does is make what word
makes sense next right in this context
and you know it does that through going
through billions and billions of
parameters uh which are essentially
patterns in tokenized language uh and
Chachi BT has been sort of is a guided
version of that which makes it you know
both much more useful but also much less
offensive and so that makes it a bit
more practice tactical it just makes it
a bit more a bit more usable for for
everyone yeah that's one thing I really
like about chat GPT is that it has
opened a lot of people's eyes a lot of
folks thought of this as an abstract
uh challenge or threat or development
but then when you can put a prompt into
an app and then it spits out a college
level essay and you can do that for any
topic Under the Sun
for any type of content including
even artistic Creations like poetry then
you're just like oh wow this really is
going to be uh extraordinarily
disruptive the thing everyone has their
kind of like holy cow moment with with
using this stuff I mean mine came when I
was using a program called pseudorate
which was attached to gpt3 and I had it
I I used a Samuel Taylor Coleridge poem
like Kubla Khan this on this great
unfinished poem by Samuel Taylor
Coolidge and I had it finish it and it
finished it exactly the way like no one
would be able to tell that Samuel Taylor
Coleridge didn't write it and so that
was my moment where I was like oh my
this is going to be big this is going to
change a lot of things you know I'm
going to share random story with you
that maybe some readers and listeners
will appreciate about this so I ran for
president as people remember and I
started out writing a newsletter to my
supporters uh and my list was not very
large at first it was literally me
updating friends being like hey guys I'm
you know going to Iowa for the first
time I'm doing this I'm doing that uh
and then eventually the campaign went
into full gear and my team sat me down
and was like hey you can't write this
stuff we are going to write stuff for
you because uh your Cadence is wrong
um you know you're uh you know frankly
gonna get like you're consumed by doing
other things and there was a minute when
I was dubious where it's like can you
guys write uh for me uh can you write on
my behalf and then I started looking at
some of the message they were putting
out and some of them were clearly not
supposed to be me but some of them were
kind of supposed to be me and my voice
and they were able to simulate my voice
um to a level where I was like wow you
know I thought I was important or
indispensable but then you actually
could yeah and so yeah so so AI can do
the same thing for you know most folks
and most processes in most
Communications oh yeah well I mean I
used a a program I mean the one thing is
like you know chat gbt is just one of
these like open AI is just one of these
like there are many other like I use
cohere which is a Toronto company which
I think for that kind of thing is
actually Superior and for a lot of other
things is superior I mean I just got
some information from an Israeli company
where they do basically what Chachi PT
does but then they
cross-referencing and check it against
the internet so what you get is fact
checked as you receive it I mean those
haven't hit the public Consciousness yet
but they're going to right like versions
of that are going to but you know I know
you had me on here to talk to me about
GPT but I'm actually very curious about
I like the political consequences of
this and I'd really like your thoughts
about it because like okay they can
imitate your newsletter absolutely
um like I I think at this point that
that technology is just negligible like
obviously there's a program that could
write like anyone on earth right and
certainly it could write like you right
what like how would you use that how do
you think people are going to use that
so first let me let me say to everyone
listen to this I actually write my own
newsletters
and also
um you know I've written a number of
books uh you and I actually have a book
coming out later this year yeah um and I
wrote every word of my books um I
imagine you write every word of your
books the book that we have coming out
later this year is a novel uh it's
called the last election a warning and
it's about uh third party presidential
candidate uh in let's say the next
election
um and you wrote that that novel that
manuscript and so you and I still
believe obviously in human expression
and the rest of it yes but but the
political implications first I this has
been a wake-up call to a lot of
journalists in particular and a lot of
journalists are very precious about
themselves
they think like oh you know like I'm I'm
I'm special and I'm awesome and I'm
smart and then when they realize that
Chad GPT can write like them uh or can
write at a level of expertise that in
some ways uh is superior
um then then that's uh then if you can
shift journalists
perceptions of what AI can do then
that's actually a big deal even
politically
um because then let's say if a candidate
is running on hey ai's gonna eat a lot
of jobs and change a lot of things
journalists will be a lot more receptive
so that's uh impact number one but I
mean I'm just wondering like you know I
feel like I'm out here using this stuff
in some really weird creative ways that
I'm pretty proud of right like I'm using
it like I wrote a short story that was
where I built bots of various different
literary voices and then had it create a
short story out of those things and I'm
working on a prompt story with an
engineer here which will be an infinite
story it'll be regenerative it'll be
like the same story told a different way
every time you click on the button and I
think though that kind of stuff is just
super cool but you know one of the first
things when you sign up for open AI is
it says you can't use it for political
speech but that that that obviously
can't last right like someone is going
to use this as a technique or I mean
here's the other thing it is social
media already so filled with Bots and so
filled with fake speech that we won't
even notice if there are generative AIS
out there making this stuff like I mean
is it is it already so polluted that
like we won't even be able to tell it's
almost that polluted I don't think it's
going to make as big of a difference as
you'd imagine for a few reasons number
one most candidates don't write their
own anyway uh you know so what's
the difference between a human human
speechwriter or team of speech writers
which is what the major candidates have
and then an AI I mean the AI is faster
and cheaper but in terms of your
experience as a consumer you know
there's no difference the the second
thing is that
um unfortunately I say unfortunately so
right now everyone is getting overloaded
with Communications I just saw a piece
today about how the response rate to
texts and emails and all that stuff is
going down the average American is so
sick of getting Deluge and bombarded
with stuff that even if you have ai
generated speeches and content thus the
noise is so cacophonous at this point
can you just ballpark performing can you
like honestly because I don't I'm in
Canada so I don't get any of those but
like can you ballpark like how many
political messages you think you got
over the midterms like are we talking
2000 like how many how many does Andrea
and get in an election cycle uh well so
at a certain point I went through uh and
started
um filtering everything right you know
so I did a manual filtration process and
talking about this is funny because you
know I know people listening to this
have gotten a lot of emails from me
right and and forward so you know like
and I apologize
um to the extent that is overboard
um it's one of the uh really unfortunate
facets of the time we live in but the
number of messages I got is easily in
the thousands and in the the in terms of
text messages I'd say hundreds
wow oh hundreds okay yeah yeah text
messages I mean they're different
channels and it used to be that text was
like the
um the great New Frontier where because
if you get a text you read it yeah you
know what I mean like do you read every
email you get no do you read every text
you get yes but have has it gotten to a
point where I get texts that almost
don't register because I see it's like
another spammy text from some campaign
oh yeah like it's gotten to a point now
where the odds of my responding to a
solicitation via text have have dropped
uh near zero or zero and that's
happening not just to me but it's
happening to you know millions of
Americans so you don't think large
language models aren't going to affect
that because it's already it's saturated
right oh yeah like we're getting
bombarded they're just trying to squeeze
squeeze squeeze uh now will it make
generating uh this content in these
communications uh faster more efficient
cheaper yes is it going to make the
cacophony worse yes
um but are we add a saturation point
where they're sharply diminishing
returns also yes
podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep I've
always been into sleep as one of the
best ways you can invest in your own
health and the way you can sleep better
is by getting a new mattress from Helix
sleep just take a personalized quiz at
helixsleep.com and they will send you a
mattress out of their 14 individual
mattress types that will give you the
sleep of your life and if you don't like
it you can return it risk-free for up to
a hundred nights I know it's bananas
Helix has been awarded the number one
mattress pick by GQ wired and my kids
who seek it out it's their favorite
mattress in the house and there are some
mattresses that frankly I spent more
money on than the Helix mattress Helix
is offering up to 350 off that's a
bigger amount than ever all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com slash
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with the Helix better
sleep starts now
[Music]
did you see the New York Times piece
about like Chachi PT and democracy came
out yesterday because I mean I just had
a very
I mean I just like first of all I mean
one of the things that frustrates me
about the media response to large
language models generally is they they
only look at one model right they only
look at open AI which I think is like
you're not going to see the full
progress of this uh unless you see the
other things because open AI genuinely
is very responsible they're they're
probably the most responsible of all of
these AI companies right and like and
and they're they're taking very
aggressive steps to rein in some of the
negative effects of this um so I I don't
like that but also it's just this this
narrow-minded focus on them both as sort
of monster and
um
and save and like the only version of
people doing this means that they don't
see like you you can design your own and
there are lots of companies you can go
to to get to get your own version of
this that will do things that open Ai
and chat GPT won't do right and so that
that seems to me like they're both
missing the point of the politic the
political Dimension and also obsessing
over it too much like it probably will
be overrated you know like in in some
sense the effect of that well it sounds
like you're saying hey they're gonna be
all these nefarious uh janky AIS that
are used for
um very negative anti-social purposes uh
yeah so so chat EPT won't write Neo-Nazi
propaganda correct or whatnot but then
these other AIS will and so will you see
um will you see all sorts of new
virulent stuff uh getting pumped out
um uh yeah you will uh you know is it
going to be very bad for democracy yes I
agree with you that the focus on chat
GPT is very high I don't mind it again
as much because like this is mainstream
to this conversation yeah where but I
agree with you that these safeguards
don't exist uh for a bunch of other
um companies yeah I mean very I mean not
that I like everyone that I talk to in
the AI space is very aware of the
ethical problems that it I mean once you
feel its power you immediately sense the
potential ethical pitfalls right like
that's they're they're very clear
they're they're actually super naked you
see them really directly but I and I
think they do that in my experience
they're all taking them very seriously
but on the other hand you know human
beings can find their ways around a lot
of safeguards so there were a couple of
things that have come out in terms of
mainstream concern about chat EPT in
particular and you wrote an article in
the Atlantic about one of them which is
college essays in Academia uh and
apparently a lot of college students are
just like wait why am I sitting here
writing an essay when I can just
freaking uh get get this bot to do it
for me and there have been a number of
students that have already been caught
doing that and there's been a freak out
in the humanities which is already
diminished uh markedly over the last
number of years in terms of students but
now everyone's like look man like you
know I can spend years trying to figure
out how to dissect this literary piece
or I can just have a bot do it for me in
30 seconds well I mean I think it's like
the humanities are the ones that I
thought about because it's so it's like
the essay is the basis of the humanities
it's basically all you learn to do but
like the people who are really freaking
out are like mbas right and like like
the people a lot of these a lot of
things work on like in take-home exams
dead don't like never anyone who assigns
a take-home exam is not providing an
efficient method of of controlling
anything else except your access to to a
large language model at this point I
mean my kid my son who's in uh grade 11
in high school he said to me like uh he
overheard in the hallways the other day
like somebody say hey did you do the
biology assignment they're like no I
just got the I just got chat GPT to do
it right like it it's it it's like it's
already here
um it's already it's already happening I
mean the one thing I did get wrong in
that piece is I didn't think I didn't
think Academia would respond as quickly
as they did right but they're they are
you're right they're freaking out I mean
they're like you know I have a friend
who says he's going on who's an Italian
professor at University here who said
he's going straight to uh
um oral exams like like he's just like
he's just gonna go to oral exams
followed by an in-class essay right
which is like I mean the last time they
did that seriously in a university level
was the 19th century like that's like
the Oxford method of education but I
think we are going to have to go back to
that it would be very hard to fake that
stuff I mean that there there's a lot of
chicanery happening in admissions
processes where people submit these
outstanding materials then you meet them
and you're like what the heck like
there's a massive disconnect so it might
place a premium on in-person interviews
for admissions at every level
a hundred percent well I mean I think
certainly you know I think if you I
don't think people have been talking
about it for admissions essays to like
Ivy League schools and stuff because
that's obviously so Central to people's
lives and that like journalist lives
yeah exactly right no doubt about it but
I don't think it would I don't think it
would be very useful there because you
know what Chachi PT is really good at is
and all these large language models
ultimately are very good at is um filler
boilerplate you know stuff that is like
that is not that is not necessarily like
uh a personal expression right like and
I think one thing that's going to happen
is you're going to see a lot more uh
emphasis on the personal on the
intention of the author of an essay
being involved rather than you know what
the way I was taught how to write essays
which is basically still how I make my
living is like here's an idea give your
own perspective on it using sources in a
very standardized you know mechanical
way
um in in a structured argument and like
that's what I was taught from the age of
six to the age of
25 really like that like that's that's
that that was my education was how to do
that and Chachi BT does really it
doesn't break into the power of the
intention it doesn't break the power of
being able to make an argument but it
definitely breaks like the the just
simply being able to put things in a
paragraph in a good structure in a way
that makes sense right and you know that
was a very hard-fought skill for me and
now you can do it with a click of a
button right so it's not going to change
everything but a big thing is definitely
changed yeah my move uh now I'm going to
be helping
um you know cheaters everywhere but
whatever my move would be to uh have it
generate all of these uh paragraphs and
then I just go through and edit and
tweak everything and try and like
personalize it exactly Etc et cetera I
mean that's a breeze what it ends is the
blank page like the confrontation with
the blank page which is like the torture
of writing like that is the hard part
for sure
um it just removes it right and yeah
like people are saying well they're
gonna Watermark the text and so on but
like you know these are ultimately you
can if you change a word in every
sentence they're not going to be able to
tell if you make the punctuation poor
they're not going to be able to tell
like gbd3 has perfect punctuation right
so if you make the punctuation slightly
off
um they will not be able to tell right
so this is a this is now a crib sheet
for cheaters Andrew Yang and Stephen
Marsh
but I mean essentially my spotting
software
you know that like there was one of the
one of the first students who was caught
in New Zealand was like they said
cheating right and and they said
um it's not cheating you told me I
couldn't use other people's work but
this isn't other people's work this is a
machine right like if you go by your own
definitions like I'm allowed to use a
thesaurus like when I was a kid this is
dating me a little bit but when I was a
kid like I was not considered any good
at English or writing because my
spelling was not optimal it was good but
it wasn't great and my handwriting was
terrible right and those were the
metrics of you know Elite literacy when
I was 10 years old right like it's now
like spelling used to be half the battle
of getting a grade in an English class I
I want a spelling bee in fourth grade
but continue did you yeah what was the
word you want on can you remember I
forget it wasn't even that hard it was
like fastidious or something whatever of
course of course you won a spelling bee
that makes that absolutely perfect sense
to me
if you know me you know that I believe
we should own our own data and right now
big tech companies are tracking your
every move online one way you can
improve this situation is to use
expressvpn I like expressvpn and use it
on several devices you can use it for
under seven bucks a month after all I
don't want my personal data to get
access for the profit of someone else
plus I like being able to access content
from around the world just literally tap
one button on your device to turn it on
and you're done no more big companies
snooping around my business if you don't
like big Tech tracking you and selling
your personal data for profit it's time
to fight back visit
expressvpn.com yang right now to get
three months of expressvpn for free
that's
expressvpn.com Yang once more
expressvpn.com yang
foreign
[Music]
that came out is that Google is freaking
out because if you have chat GPT
um then maybe uh you can get the results
you want
um without their proprietary search
engine algorithm and Bing a good old big
I I try to be in a debate being
announced that they're going to try and
integrate with chat GPT in the next
couple of months
um so the fact that Google as soon as I
saw that I was like oh that makes sense
you know that this would be a threat
um but there are probably dozens of
other companies that should be thinking
in the same way I mean I kind of am
exhausted by Google searches I don't
know about you but like when you do a
Google search like to find the actual
valuable information that you're looking
for on the particular question you asked
you really I mean it's not like it's not
that it isn't there but you know there's
so much trash out there that to Wade
through the trash to get to the actual
reliable information is very hard now
what chechi PT has that Google doesn't
have is it hallucinates right so it
gives very convincing answers that are
whacking you have no connection to
reality right
um but if you were to fuse that with a
search engine where it kind of removed
that it removed the hallucinations and
it showed you the sources of what you're
doing I mean I find the thing the uses
of of chat GPT I mean
like I had I had friends who were like
involved in like LED lighting and like
this really bizarre technical question
that's essentially used for very minor
forms of Show Business and they have
they face a series of problems right
like that they add that everyone in the
field faces and they just put those
problems into chat EBT and they were
like it gave us a different approach
than it than we we thought about right
which is I mean that's extraordinary
because that's not just like what is LED
lighting how do you use it here are the
answers it's like it actually gives you
a cohesive argument that might give you
a different way to think about it which
might even be more valuable than Google
right
um but you know the other thing is like
I have a friend here who you know I'm in
Canada so French immersion is really
important right every we're all putting
our kids in French immersion so that
they can grow up to be prime minister
and like his son didn't like any of the
French immersion books that they were
reading at school so he went to Chachi
BT and said write me a book at this
grade level in French about my son's
favorite superhero and it did right how
long is the book how many pages sure you
know I mean short books like but you
know that like that we we're still in
175 billion parameters with chat with
GPT through chat GPT like there's going
to be a massive Leap Forward I mean
maybe this month like when they released
yeah yeah I know they're talking about
Chad gpt4 yeah and like I mean I've
looked at I've had access to Google's
Palm which is 540 billion parameters
they wouldn't let me use it on my own
but they they showed me what it was
capable of doing and I mean it's it's
love it's capable of things that are
just really freaky I mean just
incredibly freaky low level chain
reasoning and uh like translating words
that don't make sense into foreign
languages that that somehow is capable
of making sense in them uh like it it
it's it and and having interior
languages that or I mean it's very very
weird right so like we're still in like
I would say that I thought that GPD 3
was the model a chat EBT is the Model T
but somebody's eventually going to make
a Lamborghini here right like somebody's
eventually going to make like the a
really extreme art of this technology
and I mean and that and that's going to
be totally incredible and that's going
to have a whole range of consequences on
everything that involves language so
you're saying that Chachi BT is at 175
billion Google's AI was at 540 billion
uh now chat EBT is getting smarter all
the time
um so that number is going to go up uh
gbt4 is going to come out sometime this
year
um that there's no theoretical limit to
the number of uh words and data points
that one of these models can consider
right so you're looking at a trillion
probably sometime pretty soon and uh Sam
Altman came out and said uh uh the way
to think about it is that the past is
um horizontal and the future is vertical
in terms of the exponential growth rate
um and suggesting that because of the
rate of improvement uh you could be
looking at what what they call
artificial general intelligence or AGI
or something like that some something
that can reason
um you know in a finite number of years
I mean someone was suggesting a decade I
am um I'm what you what would be
considered a hard AGI skeptic
um like I don't think this is any
anything that I've used right and
anything that I've seen certainly
Google's Palms certainly all this stuff
um is no closer to an artificial
Consciousness than a pocket calculator
right like this is the way to think
about this is this is the pocket
calculator of language right it can do
what you tell it to do in incredible
ways that are superhuman right that no
human being can match and and certain
those abilities as they get better are
going to be totally extraordinary but
you know one of the key things to
understand is that there's no
falsifiable definition of consciousness
right like there's no we don't like not
that there aren't brilliant people in
this field but the brilliant people in
the field are very clear that
um there's no definition for even
something like the sensation of red
right never mind something like
self-awareness so so Stephen I think
about this in Practical terms so I I
referenced uh there are two million
Americans who work at call centers right
now yes uh make 17 bucks an hour uh
generally High School grads maybe one
year of college something along those
lines I I can easily imagine AI getting
the point where I call uh customer
service and then a bot picks up and
talks to me
um in a way that's indistinguishable
from a human
um and maybe even probably better you
know than human customer service
um I feel well served
um this thing's not going to be anywhere
close to AGI no we won't be related yeah
yeah it won't be related like you know
it's like like as soon as you get to a
point where it can lead a successful
human interaction in a way that is is uh
indistinguishable
um from the outside
um and so I I mean I'm with you that
when I talk when we're talking about AGI
and people talk about Consciousness uh
like what what you really need is just
the ability to simulate Consciousness or
the appearance of Consciousness I mean
look around the world we don't have a
lot of respect for the consciousnesses
that we are human right like they're not
particularly like consciousnesses that
are human are not particularly valued
right like we do a lot of terrible
things to those Consciousness why would
we why would what is the utility value
of another Consciousness it's actually
negligible right like or even negative
like even negative when I use this in my
book is like when the Uber driver starts
talking to you sometimes you're just
like oh man I don't want to have this
conversation exactly I mean I think I
like the phone center you know one like
that the the AI voice stuff is still not
like it's not as as far as the NLP I
mean it's there right they're making it
oh no it sucks right now but you know
but you know
one of the things like I've really tried
to do reporting on AI is like two things
one is I only believe what I see right
like there's so many rumors and there's
so much hype and
um and like there's just a lot of fraud
right like frankly there's just fraud
and like so like you know there was
rumors a year ago that like China had a
trillion parameter
um or artificial intelligence language
model
um you know a trillion is kind of a cut
off number because that's the number of
neurons in the brain right so like
there's there's some there's some
theories out there like Jeff Hinton has
speculated that when you cross that line
there might be certain effects that are
really really strange right it's kind of
like breaking the sound barrier like we
don't quite know what's on the other
side of that I mean I've heard rumors
that gpd4 is a thousand trillion
parameters right so I don't know what
that would I I don't know what that
would mean either but I kind of you know
my feeling is sort of whatever
um the other thing is that so I only
believe I see but when I see it I
believe it that's a reasonable standard
yeah because people do people some a lot
of people see this stuff and they're
like oh it doesn't matter it's like it's
you're overrating it's like no no like
when you when you see this and you like
it is going to it is gonna we have to
face this very very clearly right
um and the effects are exactly things
like those
um
those call centers now you know AI can
flame out this is something that happens
a lot like self-driving cars like that
they were pretty clear that that was
gonna happen like two years ago right
and they have not really gotten to the
point where it crossed over Sim and
there were similar things with like
Cardiology I mean really brilliant
people were saying let's not train
cardiologists anymore like we're just
gonna have ai for this they're going to
look at the things they're going to be
able to see and you know cardiologists
have nothing to worry about so or at
least Radiologists like the folks films
right Radiologists and like there was
supposed to be phased out like no no and
and similarly like the AI that was used
for
um to solve covid had a zero success
results like they did over 200 AI tests
on it didn't get anywhere so one of the
things is this Tech is very unfathomable
right it is inherently unfathomable it
is like profoundly mysterious in some
very core level and that's why like I
would say that the the movement towards
certainly computer-based computer
assistance AI assistance like text based
that you're gonna like you're gonna go
on Amazon and have a conversation with a
robot to get you your um you know to get
you the wire that you need for your
computer that's already happening right
like that I I that's already and that's
going to remove a whole series of jobs
from the economy like for sure
um and I also think like low level legal
functionaries I mean I would I would be
extremely worried if I were a paralegal
like I mean I like I I think that is
there's going to be a lot of production
you know I mean don't stop at paralegals
like like law school graduates
absolutely yeah I mean it's yet another
like the low level functions that were
the starter functions for legal
professions like those are going to be
automated
[Music]
foreign
attorney by the way right and and so I
can tell you authoritatively that most
basic uh lawyering tasks are completely
mindless and automated right and and I
have a friend whose company legal nation
is trying to automate uh some of this
legal work and they just had a record
year so you know like I mean I mean
they're not automating paralegal stuff
as well so much as they are first in uh
second year associate work
exactly I mean that I I would be very
worried about that I mean I I people
talk about like the creative professions
like AI like AI design stuff I mean I
just don't see it like I mean like it's
gonna be like I used that app that
produced all those uh images yeah pretty
cool right
like
I could do in terms of design and and
visual arts it was
um impressive and voluminous enough
where if a human designer had done that
I would think wow that's like uh you
know that that's valuable work exactly
but I mean you know San Francisco Opera
Company they did an AI generated
campaign
um but they employed 30 people
right to make it happen right like it's
not it it's not like I think there are
some very low level forms of design that
it's going to replace but I actually
don't think that you could you would
trust just a random computer-generated
design without inspection you know what
I mean like oh yeah what you what like I
I think that's going to be and this goes
back to my entire uh you you have it
generate the essay and then you edit it
uh yeah like like it would be like that
it spits out all these designs and then
the human goes like tweaks this tweaks
that and then gives it to you and you're
like wow this is genius
um yeah but then at the margins that
would mean that there are fewer uh
people necessary because like that task
might have taken the designer a day and
now it's going to take the designer an
hour yeah
yeah well it's also gonna I mean it's
gonna cut down on like use of stock
footage and all this sort of stuff I
mean depending on how the lawsuits go
but uh like like I I think it's
I I mean what it what it can do very
well is the banal right like and there's
an awful lot of that yeah What
proportion of work do you think falls in
the banana category I don't know I mean
I got a letter from my bank the other
day that said Dear Mr Marsh you're one
of our most valued customers like some
human wrote that like it's kind of worse
that a human wrote it than a machine
wrote it like what do you like why does
this language come to be in the world
I think it's like like I mean and that
kind of stuff but I mean you know I
think even for things like low-level
contracts it's going to be very useful
right like like writing like formulaic
like right dude's templates already
exactly right and or write a nasty
letter from a lawyer to like you know
that's like that that like a threatening
letter from a lawyer like it's going to
be incredible I would be very very
frightened if I was a law student or uh
someone who's considering it so let's go
through just some of the things that you
can see as uh being challenged and you
know I campaign on a lot of the stuff so
so far are we listed so far we've listed
call center workers which like that
that's an obvious one uh writers and
journalists uh I mean we've already lost
60 000 local journalists over yeah I
mean I don't think AI is not going to
kill them because the ones that are left
are so it's such a like a a narrow field
anyway it's such a specialized feel
anyway but yeah it's a personality
driven thing but I I will say that
journalists are you know like being
being woken up by this uh
um it's going to to I think it's going
to challenge the value prop of college
educations in a particular way
um that there are there's already like a
mini movement of young kids being like
why am I like you know forking over
hundreds of thousands of dollars uh um
in loans and debt uh and the rest of it
uh we talked about designers eventually
it'll get to coders um which is
something that people don't really talk
about as much biggest one if you want my
Frank Opinion biggest one that's the one
that is I mean like if you go to this
thing and say translate this from python
from C plus plus to python or whatever
Immaculate and I mean it's already
replacing sub stack like it's also I
mean sorry um what you want to call it
the uh like the thing where you go to
check your code right you go to ask
technical questions and code like and
ask other Engineers like it it's chatgpt
on that stuff is incredible right it's
simply unparalleled that's one of the
farcical things about the political
statements on this is like oh let's like
teach people how to code and then
meanwhile you're like dude a lot of this
coding stuff's gonna go away
learning how to code in college like
that's suicide that's career suicide
like you were you were building in your
own obsolescence into your life okay so
here's a caveat I give so I I you know
if someone's learning to code uh the
main thing they're learning in my
opinion
um is not how to code
um it's just structured thinking like if
if someone's studies Engineering in
college
um sometimes they're not going to be
building a bridge
they'll be uh you know Consulting on a
supply chain issue or whatnot they'll
just be using the Engineering Process
um that this is what happened to me in
law school where I
uh got the entire uh training uh and it
made me into a structured thinker now
now I thought to myself uh uh being a
document editor for a large corporation
sounds like a shitty way to spend my
time so you know I I quit
um The Firm after five months
um somewhat famously
now
um but when people ask me it's like hey
like do you use the training uh I would
have to say well you know made me a more
organized structured thinker
um so if you study something that makes
you think better
um then even if the skill itself goes
away then you know that the training
remains
um that said that they're going to be a
lot of coding opportunities that
completely disappear as AI eats them up
well I think I mean you know there was a
piece like AI eat software like it's
slowly eating software like that's for
sure true but you know I mean what I was
really worried about in that Atlantic
piece is like the essay you know you
don't have to grow up to be me who's a
professional essay writer for this to be
relevant like the way we teach people
how to think exactly what you're saying
like structured thinking is by teaching
them how to write essays and how to do
low-level legal functions and how to do
and you know code right and those those
those ways like being being forced to
make something from scratch
writing it or coding it is a hugely
important intellectual process that
matters for your education even if it
doesn't result in you you know taking
that and that becoming your field and
that becoming your whole future right
and right now like
if you're a student are you still going
to learn how to do that stuff if it's
just like click if it's just like you
know even even wanting to learn how to
do it like I wanted to learn how to
write like that that was like I wanted
Mastery of that I wanted control over
language and
um now if if if you look if you're
learning it to compete with you know
just an automated
but basically
um why would you learn it right like
that like the like the motive Force to
learn it I it seems to me is going to be
hugely challenged and so that's not even
like call center jobs or you know or or
creative jobs and things that's like
actually like the structure of how we
teach people to think is at stake right
I mean that's what's at stake and that
to me is like I don't know what to think
about that
right like I don't know where I don't
know what would we do without that
as you are I've got two boys who are ten
and seven and they are developing in
completely different ways than I did
where I was a bookworm and all I did was
read books
um and now I write not like you do I'm
not like a professional essayist yeah
but uh but you know I do a lot of
writing and thinking
um and my kids uh are learning
um through a more visual style I mean
you look at kids today uh at least in
the US and it's probably true in Canada
too
um but they just inhale Tick Tock all
day and they they think in uh a
different medium and I have young people
who've worked on my campaigns who are
really gifted and proficient in those
forms of communication where they'll be
like okay Andrew do this give me this
five second video and then they uh put
something together and then it gets
millions of hits and I'm like all right
and that's the other way I think like I
write paragraphs um and so when I see my
kids learning in a completely different
way there's part of me that despairs
there's part of me that's like I wish
you were just reading books all the time
and then you you would learn how to read
and write an argue and all the things
but then there was part of me that's
just like uh you know like am I just
someone who's trying to recreate my own
training ground out of uh some sort of
yeah
well no I feel it I mean my son goes to
a an Arts High School right and he's in
the film program and like I you know
it's fascinating because like you'll go
I'll go to these like film nights where
they'll show like the students like
60 second films like every student in
the school will do a 60 second film
right or like whatever however many are
in the program 80 kids or something and
they're all capable of creating a visual
language yeah right like they're like
like I couldn't do that in a million
years if you gave me a camera and said
like like it's not even that some of
them are superb and some of them are
like actually filmic and have like scope
and they know shots and they know how to
do things and they and and they're
absolutely that is absolutely structured
thinking right they're thinking through
technical questions they're talking
through Visual questions they're
thinking historically they're thinking
they're making references and I mean I
was just so I had the same reaction as
you because in a way it was like you're
doing film at school like you're like
like that's what you're doing but on the
other hand they're clearly
their intelligence is at work they're
processing the world in that way and
they just the the atmosphere that
they're in is so visual that like the
like everyone has their own sensibility
they can absolutely create a visual
sensibility at will which you know I I
can't right like like yeah yeah and so
so because of that I think of it as
generational
um yeah though the one way this does
come out um which I will say is a
negative is that it seems like half of
the kids I encounter aspire to be
influencers uh because they they uh
absorb that as a means of success and
then just think oh let me be that
um and that's very natural for kids you
know it's like if you see people in a
certain
um context uh so that's that's bad I
don't know what to say well I think I
think the celebrification of the world
you know is another Force that's uh
that's I guess it's part and parcel of
the rise of visual culture but yeah
that's very that's very toxic but you
know I do take like going to this High
School where these kids are they use it
in a more sophisticated like it's like
they've like this is like it's their way
of writing an essay do you know what I
mean like it's their like and that I
appreciate and there's like there's
intelligence and structure yeah talent
to it exactly yeah and work like huge
amounts of like and also like tell and
and watching the past like going and
studying you know movies from the 30s
and 20s and you know and all that stuff
and like processing it all and figuring
it out and you know I think that like I
I take I take great hope of it even as I
share with you like you know I was
raised on 60 60 cents essays from the
time I was six right and it's also what
I'm really good at you know and it's it
is being devalued right there's no
question about that
um and yet there will always be a place
where yeah of course
I mean there's still radio man like
people actually do radio out there like
terrestrial radio like there nothing
ever dies but it's uh you know the new
world is being born for sure so let's
try and sum up the the uh conversation
on chat GPT and AI more globally
um you're someone who does see around
corners you see what's coming
um your your uh book the next civil war
definitely does that it's even called
dispatches from the American future
um so what how do you see uh the
adoption and use of uh AI impacting
people over the next let's call it uh 24
to 36 months well okay I mean I think
there are
like the specifics I would I I don't
know right like I don't know I don't
know whether it's going to be like call
center jobs are gone and the predictive
capacity of people around this stuff is
poor piss poor like they just they get
it wrong all the time brilliant people
get it wrong all the time because this
technology is fundamentally unfathomable
it's very hard to say where it's going
however I will say that
um what I would say is that we're about
to enter a phase
which is not even 24 months away I think
it is going to be become clear over the
next six months where language is no
longer the
territory of the human
and our association of language with the
actual functioning of a human brain
um is going to blur and I mean I have a
piece coming on the Atlantic City or
Ivy's coming out soon called the big
blur where I think this like what we're
going to see is this blurring of
language with Automation in a way that
will be extremely difficult to tell
apart we'll be will be will require a
very great amount of
focused energy to um to check like I
think fact checking is about to become
something that we teach every kid like
like starting at a very young age like
the ability to tell a nonsense from
sense like that's going to be of much
more value than being able to write a
coach in three sentence paragraph right
like because you're gonna be constantly
faced with the situation where I mean
we're already there honestly like it it
only it didn't even need AI but AI is
just going to push us over the wall
where when you read something online
you're going to have no sense of its
validity at all you have no sense of its
human context you're going to have no
sense of it's and you're gonna have to
work to parse that and to figure that
out so I know that's not a very
satisfying answer because it's so broad
but but the truth is like
um
that is going to change how we feel
about the very functionality of language
on the most basic level on like on the
most uh on the most basic level of what
what is a text and what is and what does
it mean to get a text right and to
receive uh to receive communication
right and so you know I think alongside
that they're very like obviously I made
a prediction about the college essay
right I mean I and I think
that's just a very clear example where
you where you're where you're focusing
on language where language is the
subject
um there's going to have to be complete
rearrangement of all institutional
thinking around it and I think that goes
for the law I think it goes for I mean
you know what are what is going to
happen when people make Bots and they
say Slanders about people who is
responsible what is the what is the like
what when you if you don't if you're
creating bots that don't have you don't
have linguistic control over but you're
shaping them in a certain way what is
liable in that case like that's
something that you know no one has put
five minutes thought into but it is
about to become a real question right
like that that is become a very serious
question because it you know it's
absolutely going to be out there right
um like and it's going to and it's going
to exist so I think we're actually very
poorly prepared for this moment like our
traditional understandings our
traditional hopes and fears about
linguistic intelligence machine
linguistic intelligence have been so
Fantastical and so science fiction that
the reality is hitting us really by
surprise and it's going to be a lot of
you know like the call center example is
great that's what that's where this is
going to be fought right like that's
where that's where the future of this is
actually going to be determined does
that actually work I think it will I
mean if you're at like if you're betting
on it I would bet on a fully automated
call centers
within five years for like I I mean I
just I just I just think they'll get
there the money is it's so worth it
right as someone who is actually you
know interacted with call centers uh
yeah man I mean five years is way too
long I I think it's I think that that
thing happens quick uh well Stephen
we'll have you back in six months uh in
any case uh yeah
for sure we'll talk about yeah we'll
talk about our book more then yeah we
can follow up on this conversation talk
about it hell you know we'll have you
back uh well before then because this is
such a fascinating
conversation uh you certainly made me
think about some things uh differently
and I think about the stuff a lot so uh
I think well I'm fascinated by your take
on it politically I mean it makes
because it's so easy to exaggerate this
stuff too it's like oh it's going to
change all political discourse but it's
like when you're actually in the when
you actually understand the nitty-gritty
of political discourse it's like well
actually probably won't change it much
you're already in a space where the the
language is so automated that it
probably won't actually have that much I
mean that's very that's that's you know
I I think that's key to this
conversation is like
look at the Practical questions on the
ground of specific discourses because
that's where that's where the changes
will be yeah I mean if anyone should be
using this it would be someone like
Trump uh who clearly yeah is I you know
like isn't writing his own stuff that's
for sure and uh and and
every and everyone's like what the heck
is he doing like is he even really
running for president just seems tired
it seems bored
um this Army of trump Bots that's yeah a
future that we want oh my God so keep an
eye on that campaign because if if it's
gonna show up it's gonna show up there
Stephen such a pleasure check out his
book the next civil war and certainly
his next book co-authored with with uh
Yours Truly
um the last election coming out
September 5th of 2023 and awesome to
discuss and hopefully improve the future
alongside you my friend yeah always
great to talk to you Andrew
foreign